i'm not gonna lie to you if i'm him
and i'm saying peg me like the bad [ __ ]
i am with this mentality and out of
those 500 someone actually comes back
and says hell yeah
oh
oh
it's going on it's going off and i'm
lubed
i'm gassed
through it on gas
[Music]
what's going on yo people what's going
on it's monday fun day hey
i see someone comment one time like our
biggest ick when you call monday fun day
i didn't even see that i didn't see that
but couldn't get it i'm glad you didn't
see it and yeah [ __ ] that person
[ __ ] that person monday funday it is
monday start your week right with us you
know it's the best way and only way to
do it and if you're like james like you
said we drop on a monday he'll listen on
a tuesday maybe start your week tomorrow
as well yeah man so um
guys
you may have heard through the grapevine
that
we hit a million tick tock the other day
so to take a second and self
congratulate
we're different now
your boys are built different now
um
your boys take to platforms like a virus
yeah
like our omicron yeah sng omicron
yeah we jump on this what's this oh it's
tick-tock what's that
let me let me let me try it i mean
oh no we're infectious now yeah oh wow
it's so much easier to get followers on
here a million is that good
[ __ ] idiot a million is that good is
that a ballpark figure yeah what's good
for a tick tock i don't understand oh i
don't know like 5 000 is pretty good oh
wow oh we're clear yeah we're clear oh
[ __ ] sorry i made a next platform
what's the next one
where's the next one yeah because
tiktok's completed she's done check
check check yeah
it's done uh so yeah guys that's all
thanks to you guys um
tig talk has blessed us and allowed us
to reach out to so many of you and
that's the reason that you're listening
to us today so
uh thanks to tick tock thank you you
guys and uh yeah man it's it's been a
fun ride
and 202 has gone alright so far it's
going great so that this year will be
i feel like will be our best year not
like
not even just from
the three years we've been doing the pod
or the two and a half we've been doing
the pod but just our best years period
bro oh bro it's um it's going to be the
best year i've lived period best and
that's thankfully
down to you guys ma'am you guys have
done so much for us you've done so much
for me done so much for him and it's
you've done so much for yourselves as
well like you guys have caused and
created a community as well that every
monday or every thursday you guys are
just tuned in laughing with us sending
us messages you know building
relationships and it's just it's lovely
to see man and we thank you guys um in
abundance
and it's um yeah man we just
this one of them once it's you you are
our appreciation for the day and it's um
it doesn't go unnoticed obviously it
never will it doesn't go on i know when
people say that it doesn't go on no
never will go it actually doesn't go on
never will go unnoticed um yeah that's
changed our lives you've changed our
lives so much and it's only been so
little so far we've changed our lives
listen it's incredible also to add to
that um thank you for all the let's see
if it's not by the time this comes out
this this is like a future thank you
because this comes out next weekend it's
already happened so future thank you
thank you for all the birthday messages
my boy's 31
bro your birthday's in a couple days
above i didn't even think about it
because we're celebrating it so far down
the line i didn't even think about this
in a couple days yeah my birthday's on
thursday bro but this would have aired
but from of my birthday wow i remember
when we did it last year and the others
do
bro if i would have clocked that i'm so
sorry i would have done something
fam don't don't one don't be sorry until
you don't surprise me like that again
i'm waiting that's mad bro your
birthday's in three days yeah
yeah
31 bro 31's old as [ __ ] oh i'm the
oldest in our group it's you're the
oldest in our group by a couple months
i'm the second right yeah then it's me
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] though in it like
jay said it a couple a little while ago
like who who do you know that's like one
no one
no one's ever met anyone who's saying 31
ah
it's um i'm actually getting old man 31.
we are old you know how i know we're old
because um to let you guys in on insight
so obviously we wanted to celebrate this
milestone the million milestones so
we're going to go out
but it's not going to happen it will
happen the day this airs yes when this
is so it's happening tonight yeah
so tonight we're going out to celebrate
yeah and in my head i want to do up the
celebration in it
but what my do up looks like now in
comparison to what my door looked like
five years ago yeah it's different so
i'm thinking tattoo
some dim sum yeah yeah yeah yeah a bar
nice music background
comfy seating 100 i was thinking about
sitting down already comfy seating
well before i'll be thinking about
bottles and [ __ ] that's it the beans
and the bees yeah yeah the magical bees
bottles and [ __ ] that's all we needed
hmm
that's what five years ago that's all i
was concerned about now i'm thinking
about like where can i lay my head to
rest at what time yeah and what time i
need to make sure we're out of the
the function
in time before [ __ ] starts closing food
wise
because i need a little scrummy scrub
before we hit the sheets
we have to of course old family we are
man uh it's um it's such a weird concept
and 30 31 like it makes it seem as if
like
your life ends at 50 kind of thing but
it's
your body feels it so early man your
body feels it so knees bro
my back my knees are fine my back's
[ __ ] but only my left knee recently
i've had good knees for years yeah and
out of nowhere bro my knee just started
hurting another day and i'm thinking i
guess it's just my time for my knees bro
i'm out here do you know how many rehab
pages i follow on instagram bro oh my
god
that's hilarious you know how many
mobility and functional
and longevity pages i follow instagram
it's a joke bro that's hilarious i just
i can't just hop out of bed in the
morning yeah i need to warm up before i
do anything oh my days oh i'm tired bro
i've been doing this tell her actually
i've been doing this you'll like this i
might actually send it to you okay
i'm putting it out there disclaimer
if it works for you it works if it
doesn't it doesn't your boy's been doing
this
warm-up i designed it myself okay but
it's basically just like a prehab stroke
warm-up for my back that i do
every session i've been in the gym for
the last three weeks i haven't missed a
session without doing this back routine
i do this i do it's pretty much similar
stretch every single session before i do
a gym before i train it takes something
i'm not gonna lie to you it takes a good
six seven minutes to get it done good
it's worth it
and afterwards
your back feels amazing
and you're ready for the workout i like
that one but on the plus side
my back has been feeling real good the
last i've been doing about three weeks
this week the last seven days or so my
backs have been fantastic okay like i'm
talking good bro oh right i don't know
deadlift yet but i'm talking it's been
good bro okay and like before like
little things like putting my socks in
the morning having to like bend over
like that my back was [ __ ] hurting oh
jesus but i did that i only noticed that
progress when i did this the other day
and my back felt fine
and before do you remember when we used
to record i'd say my back's killing me
and you'd always see me arch up like
this like my back feels fine now so i'm
going to keep going good
and i might actually make it more
difficult because it's like it's working
out though they're exercising they're
not just stretches they're exercises
okay so um
i might make it a little bit more
difficult from now up the reps or
whatever but fam
touch wood
your boy's feeling good i might be on
the mend
calm i might
guys this year is going well your boys
are now breaking into the uh the guest
space now yeah that'll be coming up very
soon in our repertoire so be looking out
for that um touchwood we're gonna have
all the guests that you love all the
guests that you don't even know about
yeah and it's just gonna be a very very
fun year with sng yeah a very fun year
with sng drake is a strong maybe
don't hold your breath don't hold your
breath but also you never know drake's a
strong mate you never know we might get
mr noctor himself in the building yeah
yeah yeah yeah you never know yeah we
yeah we reached out to his people yay
is
on the fence yeah he's definitely on the
fence yeah he's on the fence but you
never know the day before but yeah
exactly because he could say yes today
and say [ __ ] you tomorrow yeah sorry so
we're on the [ __ ] you side now currently
yeah but
give it give it some time yeah millie on
tick tock he's going to see us and he
will he's going to form a report without
even knowing he'll be tweeting a caps
lock about us soon
let's just wait and see so and then so
yay is on the fence drake's a strong
maybe strong maybe
and uh you never know bro yeah man brad
pitt is a confirmed yes
for middle to end of q4
[Laughter]
so long story short we've got guests
like yeah there's guests lined up
there's guests like i'm not going to
spoil the [ __ ] for you by polluting you
with like every other episode there's
someone on it's going to be like once a
month once every six weeks once every
two months just sporadic yeah yeah
whenever we want to do it
whenever we want to do it we'll do that
no pressure yeah none of them things
doesn't it's just about what we want to
do
yeah
yeah man um hopefully i'll be fun for
you guys and yeah man just
engulf the back and forth and we just
keep going from there yeah man um on top
of that guys you already know what to do
oh yeah so if you're watching this on
the silver screen
what you want to do for starters is
flick that
that bell
um
two fingers of death ring the bell the
notification bell to make sure you know
every single time we post okay because
it's not just mondays and it's not just
thursdays anymore we've got patreon
clips dropping sporadically so you never
you're never gonna know unless you click
the button yeah man and sometimes we
might be feeling frisky and throwing a
bonus episode sometimes we might be
feeling loopy and throwing a vlog you
never know what's going to happen you
need to ring the bell so you know every
single time we drop something for you
guys as always guys if you like the
video if you like the episode then get
on there and like the episode and as
always guys
those comments and chirps are tingling
we need the breeding grounds
white robes and yeezys okay log cabin in
the forest white robes yeezys and use
that's that's
indoctrinated that's the uniform white
robes and yeezys nothing else yeah right
oh there's something ankle socks
calvin klein ankle socks yeezys and
white robes and nut busting oh that's
what we're about damn yeah jokey jokes
and busting nuts that's what s g stands
for yes ma'am um so guys get in the
comments and chirp sitting yeah find
your partner um and do your thing okay
also pause the video or the audio right
now pause the episode right now head on
over to patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs
and sign up to the patreon it's gonna
cost you three pound a month that's
tempe a day run the p come on and from
there guys you're going to get a bonus
episode every single thursday so you may
have noticed when you're looking why
does it say episode one five one and
then one five three within my five five
where's one five two where's one five
four where's one five six it's on
patreon bro
if it was an obvious i'm saying it out
loud it's a big tree on it i'll tell you
it's on patreon every even episode is on
patreon so head on over patreon.com
forwards that shits to gigs it's three
pound a month and for that that's a
third of the price on netflix and you
get an episode every single thursday
that is every single thursday you'll get
an episode and that's when we get into
the juicy the juicy juice and you also
have the backlog of every single other
thursday episode we've come on every
other episode we've ever done if you
want to get into what better music are
we talking about what movies have we
just watched
tinder swindler what's that
head on over bro we're talking pick your
poison game what's going on over there
it's lucy goosey
it's like there's there's there's no
silence in there's no there's no cancer
culture there's nothing on there there's
no cancer causing no silence there no
nothing no believes no nothing none of
that bro um some of that conventional
stuff head on over to patreon.com three
pound a month 10p a day run the p let's
go
and without further ado guys let's get
into fire lord fuegs's fun fact of the
day let's go come on i'm feeling good
gang um so like i said to you before
this is a fun fact slash
slash trash news love some trash news
yeah
caption
man left with chronic back pain
coincidental after trying to suck his
own penis
that will leave you with some back pain
fam i don't doubt that indeed my tummy
tum would have nothing
nothing good to say about that since
you're my [ __ ] ribs
they would crack so you remember that
story to go do you remember that rumor
that marilyn manson had his lower ribs
is that true or not we don't know
i don't think anyone knows about him
that's an archaic rumor
him and his agent are the only two
people that know rags because it was a
conspiracy for a while yeah and he
neither confirmed nor denied he cracked
on with his day
and if anyone was going to do it it's
him it is marilyn manson 100 is it kanye
won't know
because they they they were paddy paddy
for a bit kind of oh they were playing
for a little bit we'll ask him when he
comes on yeah yeah we'll ask him
first question did he remove his ribs or
not yes or no because you know what
we're talking about yes or no yeah
before we continue with what you're
going through that's not name and shame
yeah did you take the ribs out or not
when we know you guys will know so stay
tuned yes anyway caption man left with
chronic back pain after trying to suck
his own penis the bloke opened the bloke
opened up in an eye-opening reddit post
about a man when he heard a crack during
his his latest attempt
latest attempt
yeah
he explained that this was certainly not
his first time he's tried to do the deed
and to be fair loads of men would have
tried it at least once
i am one of those guys i never tried let
me just put my hand up now before
everyone asks oh have you guys done it
too
the unidentified guy said every attempt
has been successful however the most
the most recent one clearly didn't go
according to plan
one day as usual getting ready this is
quotations by the way as usual one day
as usual getting ready to do my thing i
did the stretches so i could be more
elastic you know
he said on reddit today he really said
that he said on reddit's today's page i
[ __ ] up again or whatever
i was doing my thing until suddenly i
heard a really bad crack in my back
at the moment i heard the crack i had an
immense pain in all parts of my back
couldn't stand up couldn't even move an
inch in my body i literally felt
paralyzed nah
scary bro for a sloth scary bro
he said he was sitting on his bed for
about 20 minutes until he started to get
she started to get a bit of feeling back
in his back the guy dragged himself to
the kitchen to get some pain medication
and that improved his situation a little
but he's now been left with chronic back
pain ever since obviously they left the
guys um anonymous but this is the face
they use that's not him it was
an anonymous guy
but bro man said
one day as usual getting ready to do my
thing ever so basically it's not
far-fetched to assume that my man likes
to slop his top
every day it's not far-fetched it seems
like he's got the stretches down to the
t he knows what he has to do
to get the leverage he knows what you
have to do to get the why would you even
want to do something like that i don't i
don't know why you want to do i don't
know why anyone would want to do
something like that okay question
question question question question a
question question question question if
you were a girl yeah and you had when he
teased would you suck your own teeth no
fam obviously you would because you're
here no no no no no no but no no but
when i say i'm not talking like like
trying to get milk out of it like mama's
trying to say i know you're on about
sexually just like just like like you're
feeling yourself you're playing with
yourself and you're just like
because
to be fair
to be fair
guys obviously wank in it
are you asking me of course yes yeah so
guys i'm
yeah yeah so obviously you do touch
yourself to push yourself yes obviously
for a man i don't really
your boy's tool is the only erogenous
owner yeah that's all that's all we've
got yeah yeah but obviously not
necessarily but yeah yeah yeah not
necessarily disclaimer not necessarily
that's the only thing
on weekdays
so that's the only thing i'm funking
with yeah
but as a woman yeah um if fred if monica
and rachel are correct you got like
between seven and nine erogenous oh yeah
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
being one of them so again you might not
be wrong if i was a woman would i want
to get the the tea involved
maybe i don't know if i'll be sucking it
maybe a little squeeze and twist
okay i don't know sakin's a bit
intense i don't really want any part of
my own body in my mouth
in a sexual context okay does that make
sense it of course it makes sense
because as a man i wouldn't want it now
so
yeah yeah but i it's so
biased because
as a woman it just seems sexier
it's sexy for me to see it of course but
it's also sexy for me to know that they
want to do it as well
true you know but then again as a man
bias but some women find it sexy as well
true that's the thing
if you're a woman i don't know what i do
if i was a woman because i'm not
that's different all i know is if i was
a man with tits they ain't going in my
mouth
that's all i know all i can tell you is
if i was a man with tits they're not
going to my mouth
i promise you you'd probably think
different if you actually had tits
if i was a guy with tits if you're a guy
with tits i think
and
in a sense of guy with his like you have
the full mechanisms of a female of
female titty yeah the eastern is flowing
everything milk still works i but you've
got a tool as well i think curiosity
will kill you one day
i don't think it would bro
i don't need it in my mouth
if i'm
i know you raised your hand but the way
you're chatting from have you tried to
slop your top oh god no tell the truth
um
you're chatting saying the curiously i'm
not curious about it yeah i'm not
talking about sucking my dick though bro
i'm talking about ting what are you on
about fam
we're talking about sexual sometimes yep
i'm saying as a woman or as a guy with
tits as you would say but i was saying
when i asked you the question if you're
a woman would you want to suck your own
tit i wasn't saying would you want to
start your own clip there's a that's an
equivalent that's more of an equivalent
replica
fair enough fair enough i'm saying take
because especially because it's closer
that's why
okay as a guy
from what you're asking me right now i'm
not curious bro
fair enough i'm not curious in the
slightest clearly you are and i think
you would have i think i would be very
curious
what are you calling i don't know that's
the thing i have no idea i have no idea
that's fair enough i haven't i don't
have them so i don't know
but i like because it's the same way
like
as men sometimes you just leave your
hands by your balls and it's very
[ __ ] comfortable comfortable same
with women they leave their hand in
their teeth and it's very [ __ ]
comfortable so i've heard yeah but it's
a hop skip and a jump in between don't
get me wrong i know that don't get me
wrong but i'm saying because like we
discussed um before
as straight men
our one
zone is the actual tool like i couldn't
care less about my arseholes you know i
mean it's just at all so but as a woman
you've got like you said three four five
six seven you never know t is one of
them clit's one of them arseholes one of
them you know they're different places
so they've got more places to try and
tease or explore to try and find a spot
that's why i'm saying tea because it's
it's not
you're not putting like fluids or
liquids in your mouth or something
you're not excreting anything to put in
your mouth it's just it's just skin fair
enough it's just [ __ ] skin
do you know what i mean
a man and you suck titty now so yeah i
do
next thing say in it
it's awesome next thing tea but like i
don't know bro i'm saying a girl could
put stuff in my mouth and i wouldn't
think twice yeah
myself i'm not gonna put my fingers in
my arms you know what i mean for what
can you imagine can you imagine walking
into me having a walk and i'm like
[ __ ] my fingers first and foremost
first that's done four months you're not
going to walk in with me grinding you're
not going to walk in there
but that's the thing what i'm saying is
if you did walk into me having a wank
you're when you walk out the first thing
you think is was he sucking his fingers
before you even think about what you
just walked in on you'd walk out and
think was home by sucking his own
fingers do you know i mean
i lose my mind
i lose my mind i'm saying about the
curiosity yeah because skin is skin yeah
yeah yeah my fingers are skin if i'm
banging a girl yeah and then she just
i'm not thinking i'm not thinking about
anything yeah yeah yeah i'm not thinking
grandma that's not common it's usually
the other way around but i'm just saying
i won't be thinking about nothing but my
own self
yeah if i'm like
if anything's going in my mouth while
i'm bashing off
it's confusing
it's confusing so i don't that's what i
said when you said if i was a guy with
tigs
would i be curious that's why my
immediate ration is no because i'm not
curious about anything as it is okay
but like i said i'm not in that
situation so you never know okay but
then again i think we've spoken about
this before
wanking to me is a means to an end yes
we have
i don't like
from the far from when i'm
if i'm if i'm on a solo ting fam
the fastest way i can get from zero to
ten
is better for me it's a it's a mechanism
thing for me i don't do it for the
pleasure of it i do it so i can think
straight
[Laughter]
adam on eve is how i get is the
pleasurable yeah i do it so i can get on
my day yeah yeah get to sleep
it's tactical yeah i don't do it for the
enjoyment yeah
so
that's that's probably why i wouldn't be
curious okay but if i was into the whole
pleasure side of it okay then oh yeah
oh yeah all sorts okay but i never know
but um anyway
tell me about your week i have no idea
about your weekend uh bro um
i actually had a
everything i'm so annoyed because every
time you ask me all i can think about is
work i know that's what i've come from
yeah that's what i've come from on the
weekend you know i actually can't
remember what i did on my days off
um but the weekend was
very lackluster in the sense of
i was expecting the week to be or the
weekend sorry to be so hectic at work
because of the valentine's weekend blah
blah blah oh yeah
but it was it was so it dragged bro
because there were so many couples of
twos obviously it [ __ ] dragged bro
and it was just so boring boring boring
boring but nothing exciting really
happened
um
well what else did i even do during the
week
um saw the um
i saw the halftime show for the nfl
um super bowl rather saw the halftime
show for that which was really cool
um what else did i do
i trained which was good i did shoulders
one day and i did legs i only went twice
last week which was poor from me i'm
gonna go four times this week touch wood
um what else
that's annoying because i generally
don't remember bro my weak flies by fair
enough oh there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that but no
i know there's nothing wrong with it but
it's annoying because i look forward to
that question yeah yeah yeah
i know i try to rack my brain like what
did i actually do because i always
forget true always forget so what did i
do
on wednesday or whenever it was yes yes
yes um
tell you what i did forgot about that
actually tell you what i did
i went to sin i want to watch sing two
i don't even know what that is sing you
know the movie sing the animated movie
sing no you've never seen sing bro no
oh my god
sing you've got skye right yeah they've
got the movie package no all right i had
it i took it off all right say this
um because i know it's on now tv which
is basically sky yeah
um roll sing
talk to me then sing okay cool [ __ ] you
now talk to me
because to me this is basically like
trying to explain what toy story is okay
and i'm thinking how does this guy not
know what singing all right i think i've
seen it
sing is obviously so sing is an animated
movie i don't know if it's disney or
pixar or whatever but it's an animated
movie
um
where it's like a animal world all
different animals but they're like
humanoids if you will they live everyday
lives and it's basically a guy a koala
called how is it howard moon or
something moon who
is like obsessed with theater
and obsessed with just like production
and theater and he wants to be super
successful like director
of like plays and musicals and all these
things so um
he sets up this singing competition of a
prize of a hundred grand and all these
different people come together
um to take part in the singing
competition and they're all from like
humble beginnings so like one of them is
like a gorilla whose dad is like a mob
boss
um
one is like um a pig who has like 3 000
utes and she's just like a house man
said humble beginnings i said a gorilla
that his dad's a mob boss uh one's an
elephant
but fam these men are like singer
singers
like the elephant is tory kelly and she
can sang yeah
so bro yeah and they they do like pop
like actually like real songs so they're
singing they're not all like made up
they're not all like um i know what you
mean self-written songs they actually
have proper songs
the movie's live yeah the movies live
fam sing one is a movie
do you know that's how i feel about have
you seen the movie inside out yeah movie
of course it's a movie
[ __ ] movie bro that's like sing sing
the movie
when the elephant does her solo at the
end you'll get goosebumps really she
shuts it down let me let me google this
thing she she shuts it down so i watch
sing two and seen him out of the day
banging a sequel
you can't sleep on sing bro you need to
watch it stop it immediately that's too
funny bro
clay colorway porsche crystal johnny
scott joe's in there say sweat
latisha right isn't it pharrell okay
from movie bro
sing is a movie
are you sweet matthew mcconaughey is the
lead come on man he's sweet
come on man all right say less yeah you
need to jump on sync bro say less i
think it might be on amazon you have
amazon prime yeah i've got private i
think you might be on prime cool prefab
is it's a movie
you'll love it you'll actually love it
all right sorry sorry sorry sorry but
anyway um yeah yeah watch sing two
that's the lyrics off sequel not as good
as the first but that's fine yeah um
but it wasn't far off that's important
it wasn't far off it was good that's
important
i believe you either way brother yeah
yeah yeah yeah
what else is hilarious um
i don't think i did much bro i don't
think i did much
you need to watch uh what's it called
ah that's so anticlimactic oh what's it
called
um i don't want to get the name wrong
that's why
all of us are dead
fam it's been climbing up the charts
appreciate a maturity of the day
duncan swear
series
it i want episode 8 and i think it goes
to 13
series okay one thing i will say because
someone baited you out for this and i
never got
do you remember when we had the
discussion when i said
hellbound seems trash i've seen the
first episode it seems trash i'm getting
frustrated and you told me to carry on
i'll be honest i haven't carried on but
then someone put in the comments the
other week yo [ __ ] he's he called me out
he called me out maybe he dm me or
whatever is it a message or a [ __ ]
comment i can't remember and was like
james [ __ ] you hellbound is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i watched the whole thing it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i was like yo [ __ ] you yeah me
i was like what i ain't even watching it
and i was like
don't be out of my name yeah public
about [ __ ] you yeah so yeah
are you sure this is good i'm sure
brother
that they're
people are entitled to their own opinion
fair enough first and foremost fair
enough yeah
whether they think hellbound was [ __ ]
fair enough they thought it was [ __ ] i
thought it was a great show
fair enough but
all of us are dead is
hands down the one either the or one of
the best zombie apoc apocalypse show
slash movies i've ever seen all right
i'll watch it because i saw it on
netflix didn't think much into it and
then
the top 10 in the uk whatever it says it
was number two the other day i was
thinking when did it get there
when did it get there
that's that's intriguing they what is
korean i don't know whether north or
somewhere it is north of southwest
first of all it's south north korea
don't do production north korea
are not a place yeah it's south korea
okay i just know it's korean i didn't
want to make sorry mistake it's not from
north korea now okay i'm still going to
say it's korean
nonetheless bro
these guys
don't
sh what's the word i'm looking for they
don't downplay the action there's no
budget when it comes to action all right
say less there's no budget bro yeah yeah
yeah the way these men turn to zombies
the way the poetry everything about it
bro
because obviously
it's a
um it's like an apocalyptic everyone's
saying zombie robot that's the obviously
basis of the movie but the comedy in it
bro the quote-unquote romance in it the
little witty snide remarks in it they
bring every genre in it even though it's
based on this whole zombie thing the
comedy is so quirky
so quirky and so punchy straight to the
point it's jokes i'm here for it it's
jokes i'm here for it the action
the way some of these men die close
friends yeah yeah say less
say less fam squid game change the wave
in terms of allowing korean [ __ ] to come
through
i've been i've been i've been watching a
fan of korean yeah obviously yeah i've
been i've been watching korean [ __ ]
since i was a kid
in terms of just like yeah in terms of
just like normal people yeah like um
yeah like squid game changed the game
when people said oh swear down because
before if you run a korean show
on your general
for you page call it on netflix hey
wonderful watching that but
a lot of people well
i am actually assuming this but i would
like to believe
um not like to believe but i find it
hard to believe that a lot of people
watched the watched squid games in
actual career
i'm pretty sure a lot of people watching
english
sucked that or dubbed rather that's the
reason why it
fam annoying you need
you have to watch
a show in the language it's entitled
yeah you have to that's the only way you
can truly grasp yeah what these voice
actors don't know what they're doing it
just doesn't pattern well it's just like
uh yes
there's no other explanation but
it's [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] it's [ __ ] bro
yeah bro you you have to you have to
watch
um any show or movie in the language it
was it was created in because yeah you
can't be it brings that it brings a
different oomph to it even though you
don't understand what they're saying
just like you can feel what you're
feeling the energy they're trying to
portray yeah yeah and you could just
read the [ __ ] subtitles i just read
it just say you can't read subtitles
yeah just say you can't do both yeah
yeah then we'll understand why you have
it then i'll allow you
just admit it
okay i'm going to start that tonight
because i'm in the midst of not having
anything to watch every and every
episode is at minimum hour
juicy wow juicy bro eight hours in yeah
much fair play all right i'll start that
tonight good that sounds good that
sounds good
very good sorry hit number two i was
thinking it's a very very very very good
show speaking of korean stuff this has
made me so happy since i told i think
i've probably recommended like three
times but every time you speak about
korean stuff i bring up old boy
the amount of people that have messaged
me personally saying that they watch old
boy because i told them to watch it and
how much they [ __ ] love it makes me
so happy dang you've told me about oh
boy many times first time in uni
probably yeah
keep forget about
it i keep forgetting about it one of my
top movies ever i know you say that all
the time oh i love it
i love it
so many people have messaged me since we
started this pod saying [ __ ] hell
thank you physician oh boy
what a movie gang what a movie bro i
never did this last week i'm feeling
this let's have another shot
i'm feeling it
i can probably handle one more
and then i need to water up
but i'm feeling this so i'd love to hear
yeah am i wrong
you know it's a you know when you're
you know when you're watching a movie in
there on a date i don't know i don't
know like am i crazy
[Laughter]
things are just vibing yeah i feel like
we've got a connection am i crazy tell
me i'm crazy
am i crazy
oh [ __ ] guys as we said before we're
looking for a tequila sponsor you know
it's been um it's been something that's
been on our brains for a minute
um if you guys know anyone or know
anyone that knows anyone that knows us
that would love to know us
hook us up man
i um i spoke to uh charlotte the other
day
yeah and i said it to her yeah and then
the only one on her books is
patron
and i said shout out a minute and she
was like
[ __ ] please she's like come on bro
[ __ ] please i'll bring it up
the tread is basically apple they don't
[ __ ] with anyone
they don't [ __ ] with anything i was like
don't bother telling me that it sells
themselves yeah they they don't need to
pay me anything they don't need anyone
the consumer market is there oh 100
we
you guys already know the sip sip yeah
man
if you guys haven't tried a sip sip yet
let me know i was i said that thing to
you about the feather thing the other
day yeah yeah i know you guys okay
here's the thing
the sip sip is a global phenomenon all
right yeah
it has been for a while but we need to
make sure it's not
i don't know if this is politically
correct but when i was kid we just call
it chinese whispers i don't know what
it's called now yeah but he's called
chinese yeah sounds racist as hell when
you say it as a 30 year old man yeah but
back in the day used to be called
chinese whispers so for lack of a better
term
it can't be a chinese whispers thing
right the other day i was listening to
the feathers podcast
um and they the only reason i was
listening to that episode is
they had cole anderson my boy carl
anderson on this show
and
i said my boy he has no idea who i am
but anyway
though they're my boy they're my best
friend
and they were talking they were doing
sambuca shots yeah and he was
complaining about
that the [ __ ]
taste that leaves in your mouth after
doing some big shot and they got into
the topic of tequila and then one of the
hosts was like oh have you heard that
rumor about
swallowing a shot of pineapple after the
tequila et cetera et cetera et cetera i
said oh i just heard it like i don't
know where it came from guys if we're
spreading rumors we need to let them
know where it came from okay don't be
embarrassed it came from sng it did come
from sng
we're the only pod promoting such thing
because
we've got a [ __ ] t-shirt that says
tequila sip sip for blood sake yeah yeah
you know what i mean you need to be
spreading
facts actually actual facts bro yeah
just just say you saw us do it you've
heard about it through the grapevine big
up sng
here's the shot yeah man and obviously
apparently craig david started the thing
but that's hearsay so what we need to do
is get as many
signatures
on our side on our side before this goes
to court
because we can't leave yeah yeah i can't
have craig david on on this side on the
plaintiff side
chat
chat and pop saying that it's his team
now it needs to be also we need the
signatures
because i'm trying to tm it yeah oh boy
boy i'm trying to tm
yeah that's all we drink so we drink
yeah guys when you're spreading these
rumors don't say you made it up
give us the credit yeah yeah and so we
can tm the thing um but anyway
oh god
jesus so yes i will watch that show okay
i'll watch our show let me know what you
think let me know guys as well in the
comments let me know what you think
as per as well tweet along with us um
s g fam
join along in the conversation on
twitter we're active yeah we're trying
to stay more active we're trying to stay
more active on twitter guys so just join
the conversation join the fun hashtag
smgfam and we go from there mum
let us know what you think about the
series um also actually not even also
segment time sharp left turn
tinder chat oh
yes and we didn't get to do this last
week we wanted to do a live stream we
didn't run out of time yeah
so a couple weeks back obviously as we
do every friday um put a question on the
app um instagram and we spoke about
funny slash cornelius messages you've
received on the date and app had loads
we had a few laughs
but i've got a few more so here we go
i'm gonna go straight in with what was
the question oh what sorry you just said
it yeah worst what funny slash corniest
messages you received on a dating app
okay again
roses are red
violets are blue
we're having sex tonight
because i'm stronger than you
wow indeed brother wow indeed
when i read that i couldn't believe it
it takes an interesting type of woman to
reply and not block
it takes an interesting type of woman to
be like say less yes endearing you have
to
understand bantam
balls deep in the jokey jokes balls deep
you have to understand i don't mean this
in the way the general public may deem
this yeah
so less chit chat yeah yeah yeah because
this could go very left
or a quick right
yeah just let me know what you're on
yeah yeah 100 but the bravado to send
that period
next oh your buff your tinder swindler
buff
because you've you've had swipes yeah
yeah that jiffy said yeah
because i'm stronger than you bro
it's what you just have to blink twice
it's one of them once yeah yeah cool ah
question
have you ever been tasered at the point
of orgasm before oh my god
i can't even comprehend that sensation
same i can't comprehend that sensation
what a question to ask someone
i'll be petrified who are these people
bro no james these are people that
follow us
these are people that follow us well to
be fair they've received it right
yes yeah they received this question
yeah cool because they're not sending
they're
it's true that's what it is
they said this could be you and sent me
a link of them [ __ ] a sex doll
no fam
i've said this before bro
man i think you know what's concerning
to me is i know they're all guys man oh
hundred percent
100
they're all guys
and i'm concerned that i know these guys
but i don't know that i know them you
know what i mean
question all right
what would you do let's say you've come
to mind now you know what my yard looks
like everything blah blah
you come into my room now for some
reason you're just having like maybe you
want to grab a pair of boxes my pair of
boxers a pair of shorts a sign i don't
know yeah you randomly open my cupboard
and you actually see a life-size sex
though i've not told a soul about this
before
a soul you know me like you know your
brother what do you do and what do you
say
oh i'm pulling you in the room and i
want an explanation
i'm pulling you in the room i'm closing
the door because i don't want anyone
else to be exposed to this and just talk
me through it
because i am assuming you're a sound
mind and body
so i want a logical okay okay
okay
let's say i do have this sex doll right
because i feel like this is an
interesting topic because i've thought
about it not necessarily the sex doll in
itself but male sex toys or anything in
particular okay you know because i feel
like there's such a stigma when it comes
to men buying sexual objects yeah of
course
but i don't understand why because it
seems it's deemed
sexy if a girl has a vibrator or a
rabbit or this or that or whatever
but
if let's say for example you were
looking for something in my drawer and
you found a [ __ ] fleshlight for
example
it's embarrassing it's a disgrace
not saying i've got i you know i don't
have any of these things but i don't
know i don't know what you have but um i
believe you disclaimer i ain't got a sex
though i ain't got a flashlight but i'm
just saying yeah of course why
why is that dean such a not necessarily
a negative but such like a oh why the
[ __ ] have you got these kind of things
you know when a female can have the
complete
male version of the i feel like it's
just so it's a huge double standard oh
100 huge doubles 100 is like
i don't know bro i don't know it's it's
a weird one because
there is obviously also the stigma that
men are hornier
so you think it would be more acceptable
for men to have more things that relate
to being hornier
but you're right like it's just not
it's just not cool it's
i don't think cool is even the worst
yeah i don't know maybe
i'm just spitballing maybe it's
something to do with the whole kind of
uh
how do i explain it like
being a man
relating a man to sex and the acts of
sex with a man is very
aggressive does that make sense like
you're literally pushing [ __ ]
in
it's very aggressive in nature yeah
even when it's loving and tender it's
aggressive yeah
but for a woman it's very
non-aggressive i think of the word but
it's very non-aggressive
it's very gentle it's very like do you
know what i mean like is it's not
hardcore because there's because the
toys that you have for women obviously
you can get like a big fat black dildo
yeah and that's
as well yeah yeah you can get like okay
but that's the same thing
if you saw a girl with a rabbit like a
rabbit is designed to be cute and quaint
fit in your purse
it's it's designed to be very
non-aggressive yeah
but like say same thing even if you went
in a woman's drawer and found a massive
huge dildo
same thing you'd be like holy [ __ ] i
would be like rock
that would literally be wise yeah but if
you see a little rabbit or something
like that you're like normal you
wouldn't think wouldn't think i would
look at it i would look at it and think
that's that's literally normal i didn't
continue looking around i'm keep
rummaging yeah i wouldn't
pay attention i would see it and be like
cool yeah
i'll just keep moving through whatever
i'm looking for i'll just keep going and
get brushed past but like i said if you
saw something that was considered
aggressive
like
like you know them um
like the the mid-rift of the of the sex
though so some there are sex dolls and
there's there's just like the bati
there's someone with
imagine you should have a porcelain
little bite thing you just see your
batty yeah yeah that you're like bottom
torso
and a little bit of quad
fan imagine you look under my pedal side
are you just looking at you saw cheeks
knife
we need to check cause you're a buff guy
you know i mean you're a good looking
guy
but you get what i'm saying this is
sticking on your side bro are you though
i'm not saying i've got these things but
are you really on my side bro because i
need to ask the mandem and i need to ask
the girl then why is it such a huge
stigma
bro chat with us sng fandom twitter
please we need to know
because he mixes me sometimes bro i'm
actually now i am on your side
perplexing because you're right because
if i looked under your bed and i saw
perky cheeks everyone would question me
100
i would be a [ __ ] pervert you like go
to jail get out my yard i wouldn't want
to see all these random things will come
to play erosion that's you
pervy sage oh that's you no one want
anything i couldn't walk into work
brother nah because you've got cheeks
under your bed nah fam do you know what
i mean yeah but yeah
yeah it's just dread it's not it's a
dread stigma it's dread
i don't know where were we in this but
oh we were doing
stuff
but yeah it's not on bro it's not on oh
yeah it said because i was like um sent
me a link or [ __ ] a sex though and he
just went left that's scary they weren't
left
scared yeah yeah why is it in a link in
the first place
link rob he's posted this
ahead of time yeah somewhere this is on
the dock got the views and then send it
to you like pre that that's famous nah
stop that that's disgraceful oh my days
all right
she told me she's got a man then said
but i cheat though so what's up
can you imagine well turn me on bro
i hate that i have to know this
it's
it's backward sexy there's no other way
to put it but backwards sexy
because it is it just is i don't know
how to explain it so frustrating that
the way that like how like saying it
that's another double standard of course
without a shadow of a doubt because if a
guy was there and said i've got a girl
but i cheated like a cheat though
so nonchalantly
your scum of the earth
so your scum of the earth if a girl does
it every guy's like [ __ ] sexy you bite
your lip like [ __ ] i want a piece of
that
[ __ ] i want a piece of that
that's all you can think of
do you know what i mean
it's so unfair yeah yeah
this biased world it's getting to me
it's getting to me i need answers
it's getting to me and i need answers
that's all i'm saying cool
a man asked if i would wear a strap on
and peg him like the bad [ __ ] that he
is
[Laughter]
yo
like the bad [ __ ] that he is
confidence in deed
confidence
is
ah
no no let me not kink shame him no no
are you getting a king shape i was gonna
kink probably king praise no i was gonna
kink praise but i was just gonna say
he'd have more luck on grinder with that
chat true
true i don't think that's king shaming
but i'm just saying that yeah as a whole
what do you thought the fact is
like a bad [ __ ] i am of course yes he's
cleaning up i take that back of course
yes he would have a lot more um success
on grindr
but i just
i need to understand this is a lot of
sex by the way it is
tinder messages it's gonna be true i
need to understand just let me know how
jeffrey brown does
sorry come on
no free brand deals under his breath
i just need to understand
the mindset because
he's obviously not attracted to guys my
assumption
yeah he likes girls but he also likes
girls [ __ ] him
he wants a fake pee pee in his in his
arse but he wants to also still bang a
woman yeah within the same session
so yes we don't know that he wants to do
that
yes we do i'm assuming these things
obviously sorry i'm assuming these
things like you said obviously yes he
would clean up a grinder but would he
want to clean up yes
he definitely does that's why i said let
me not king shame him because just
because he wants to get banged
with some like
plastic prosthetic yeah just because he
wants to get like banged by prosthetic
let me not go ahead and say my man's gay
that's why that's what i meant by king
shaming i don't want to king shame him
so i didn't want to say it before you
forced my hand so i did say it yeah but
anyway it's not what i mean
but granted
if he's
bi then yes he'll clean up a grinder
with that chat but
yeah man that's tough it's tough
it's tough i don't think he gets bare
responses with that i don't think he
does but some men don't care some manner
in it for the numbers true if i message
500 chicks with this at least one's
coming back more than one yeah more than
one ratio would be on your side yeah
they're willing to put in the work
because if i want to have it my way
let me just go quantity over quality 100
and then a few are coming bam one's
going to come back to you and if it i'm
not going to lie to you if i'm him
and i'm saying peg me like the bad [ __ ]
i am with this mentality and out of
those 500 someone actually comes back
and says hell yeah
oh
oh
what's going on it's going off and i'm
lubed oh
i'm gassed
through it i'm
gassed it's worth the effort it's worth
it hours and hours it is it is
fair play to him
fair [ __ ] play to him
i've got no qualms about it do your
thing sir do your thing
i think i just shut i think i just shot
and ruined my pants can i get into yours
oh no
i said oh no
there's different ways we can finesse
this do you know what i mean
that needs to be draft one
and then let's let's look at it ain't
working let's literally yeah
together we can make our fingers smell
like all sorts of things
yuck
for [ __ ] sake man they're all guys bro
bro they're all guys bro
can i use you like a bowling ball and
bang you down an alley
i already know i could see the guy that
sent this i could see him a hundred
percent
wow
ah uk dons are the funniest sometimes
when it comes to sexual banter funniest
after we bang
can i not in my hand and slap you with
it
wow
bro
some of these guys are loose
loose
man said you're like a cigarette
both smoking hot and i want that butt in
my mouth fair play fair play hopefully
you got it hopefully you got a couple
swipes yeah i reckon
i want to eat your ass so bad that i can
taste your ex's [ __ ] i've heard them
things before dead
this is one of these this one actually i
posted when we did the thing but i
really like this one on a scale of one
to human centipede how close am i to
that ass i think that's genius
that's genius brother
i have to give you that you have to
message him back human scent
humans
because that's genius bam how close am i
to that ass
one donnie said wow
you sound awesome
is it bad that i wish you were my sister
he's streaming on twitch or satin fam he
can't this
that can't be a real message
this is a reaction thing it's a prank
thing that can't be a real message
because that then
does he
want a young incest i'm not your sister
so no matter what i say
what do you want me to say to that i
just don't understand what response he's
expecting yeah fam do you know what i
mean i don't know what the best case
scenario is there is never gonna be your
sister
fact so what do what do you want me to
say is it bad that was it yes
do you want me to tell you you're bad
like what was going on
bro i i read that when i was like i just
don't understand man i just don't
understand um
one has been a guy oh 100 last one guy
are you
i
are you looking for a builder because
i'd love to smash your back doors
standard guy
guy
yeah rags guy oh but that's them bro uh
they i've had them on my phone for weeks
they're just sweet at me the [ __ ]
roses are red violets are blue we're
having sex tonight because i'm stronger
than you
that
is wild
that's the wildest one of the wildest
responses
100
wildest responses we've ever 100 percent
i couldn't believe it whenever that's
different yeah the banter has to be up
echelon to even be able to respond to
something like that
he's he's getting tinder swinging the
swipes 100 because
he's willing to lose he's using to risk
it all yeah all
because there's a backlog of these
messages somewhere at tinder hq or
bumble hq
as you're typing it brother
as you're typing it they're seeing it
it's archived somewhere
i don't know what the
the the data security is like i haven't
i'll be honest i haven't used a dating
app in a long long long time i've never
even i've never i don't know what
bumble's like i don't know what plenty
of fish is like i don't know what i
don't know what plenty what else is that
obviously tinder i've been and used back
in the day there's bumble there's plenty
of fish i've used tinder back in the day
i've never used plenty of fish but
why am i just remembering who are god
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i would have died and never remembered
this yeah i mean yeah
when i was a lot younger mm-hmm
i think this was probably do you
remember when catfish the show just yeah
mtv
years ago on mtv or it was mtv yeah it
was mtv yeah yeah yeah and that was on
tlc i think or something some [ __ ] like
that yeah it was on mtv it was either
around then or maybe even before then
yeah me and my brother
signed up to plenty of fish for a joke
yeah
because we were kids yeah we thought
would be funny
to just chirps like
old divorcees okay
um this i know we're young because we
never
interpret this never happened but i'm
thinking about now we didn't even
understand that like nudes were a thing
okay i mean okay so we were just on the
computer
it's before we had laptops phones
anything we're on the main household
computer see sign up to plenty of what's
pc stand for personal computer oh go um
signing up to plenty of fish
to just chirps older women
[Music]
um
for the fun of it
we thought it would be funny if we could
get them to go on a date with us okay so
that we could see them this is dread now
so we could see them in the restaurant
by themselves
oh my god in our head
when we were young we thought it'd be
funny
oh my god
as i thought listening to you say that
as a third-year-old man is the most
dreadful thing i've ever heard
before says
you got their hopes up
they got dressed perfume makeup for the
first time in a long time we thought it
would be this is [ __ ] up we thought it
would be genuinely funny
to chirps old women
to get them to meet us at a restaurant
all dressed up so that we could look
through the window and see them by
themselves
yo wow that's so bad about it so bad
breathing in our head it was so funny
i can see the joke mentality of it i
can't do that as a 30 year old man like
31 now your brain doesn't fully develop
so you're 21. yeah when i think about
stuff like that it's so painfully
obvious yeah it makes sense your brain
is not developed yeah you can't you
don't understand empathy yeah you don't
you don't understand that people are
going through [ __ ] yeah yeah you just
think that's [ __ ] funny yeah
um if we think a woman is actually here
to meet someone and she's not here to
meet anyone in our heads that was
hilarious
so we actually did it and then but we
also didn't realize
how long it takes to build rapport with
a stranger online and then we started
messaging like two to women and we were
like this is boring
this is boring
so we locked it off after like a day
yeah so that's the my only experience
with plenty of fish
but i reckon i don't know penny fish is
so classic i reckon if you if you're
just into banging milfs
plenty of fish is the way to really i
don't even know what it looks like
i haven't seen it since i was a kid so i
don't know what it looks like now but
when i was a kid
if you just wanted like
averagely looking
40 year old women
you could clean up on penny fish if
you've been on plenty of fish tomorrow
i'm just looking for like i said average
looking devil says you're clean up
you would clean up say less 100
say less tinder obviously i've been on
years ago
[Music]
bumble i went on a short stint and then
i thought they were trying to hustle me
because i went about because obviously
bumble
the girl hasn't messaged you first yes
so i've heard yeah but then there's
bumble premium okay where you can see
who swiped you or whatever this is back
a day again okay this is probably like
five six years ago okay but though at
the time i don't know what it's like now
but bumble premium
if you signed up to it you could see who
swiped you yes if you haven't swiped yes
you tinder
everywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i
remember i logged out
i didn't log in for like a month i'd log
back in like a month later
and then it said it literally said there
were like a hundred and fifty six swipes
on bumble on bumble
sign up to bumble premium to see who
they are i remember you're i'm in for
your mom
156 [ __ ]
you're a liar
you're a liar
because by then i wasn't getting swiped
for [ __ ]
156 [ __ ]
yeah you're a liar so i canceled the
whole team yeah yeah
they may be well yeah because once i did
pay for it
i would be expecting my 156 homes
so maybe they weren't lying yeah then
maybe there was 156 but i remember
specifically 166. i remember seeing that
at work
i was working me on keynes at the time i
remember seeing that work and i said to
my colleague at the time i was like yo
he's not saying there's 156 women trying
to [ __ ]
they must be lying and he agreed with me
as i did a chat [ __ ] they just want your
money and i was like i did that i'm not
paying for this
so i locked off bamboo
oh my gosh that's too funny
it's
it's crazy that obviously yes these are
dating apps or whatever it's crazy just
how we associate with sex straight away
because in my head they've only seen my
face yeah yeah yeah so what else could
you be after yeah you only know my
physique yeah you don't know anything
else about it yeah yeah so it has to be
based on physical attraction yeah it has
to be yeah because my bio was playing oh
my i kept my bio niche very small unless
we were getting into a report you don't
need to know much about me yeah you
swipe right it means you want a bang
yeah all it means yeah [ __ ] i remember
speaking of um premium i remember when
tinder tried to do their thing because i
remember back in the day i think it was
called tinder gold or tinder plus i
can't remember but it was cheap and i
used to have it so you could swipe you
can reverse
uh so obviously when you swipe it it was
cheap yeah it was like a tenant for the
year something's huge i didn't have it
something stupid like that yeah yeah
cheapest chips yeah yeah less than a
pound a month yeah something dumb like
that yeah yeah you can reverse you can
see who swiped for you and pre them
first and then you could swipe if you
wanted to change your location you could
do bag of things you could change your
location when the last time i was on it
because i think there were periods of
time where i deleted it downloaded
delete it downloaded i think the last
time i had downloaded it
they were coming with like
60 pound a month
what
60 something
all
day
sure spro no they were mother james
mother's life i couldn't believe what i
was reading
i couldn't believe i think it's called
tinder gold i couldn't believe what i
was reading
that's impossible fab what can you do on
there now
i don't know anything about these women
i don't care i don't [ __ ] care
because they're criminals
bro i couldn't believe they were
charging
p
for to do the same thing they were doing
seven years ago nah charging p nah i'm
not doing that i'm not doing that you're
off your [ __ ] head if you think i'm
doing that just to see who swipes right
for me no i don't care that much and
just do a young reverse
i couldn't believe it but that's
disgraceful
that's the question i'm not doing that
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that at
all oh
that was i was long you know what irks
me about um
again doublelift sword
is that like
because girls
on dating apps receive so
much yeah
they get frustrated when a guy doesn't
come with anything original yeah
they hate when they say i'm not speaking
for all ghosts obviously but some of the
girls are speaking to they're just like
i just hate when they come beside
generic like
hey or what are you up to it's like hit
me with something original but it's like
but you need to understand
that
you wanted to be original because all
you get is a hundred guys saying the
same [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but he has to
send this same message to a hundred
girls it's not just you bro yeah yeah
it's bad girls so you're bored of it
because you're seeing it from 100 guys
trust me he's bored of it he's because
he sent his undergoes
yeah makes sense so even if you think
he's being original he's still copying
and pasting that to 100 girls it's never
going to be original
so next time we ask you what you're
doing just answer
because maybe he actually cares yeah
because even even if it's the most
original thing you've ever read trust me
he's copying and pasting it and sending
to everyone
so don't get gassed because he's come
with some roses or red violet blue
[ __ ] i'll rape you something
[Music]
whatever the [ __ ] my man said
that disgraceful chat we're having sex
tonight because i'm stronger than you
yeah like he whatever he says to you
that you think ah that's quirky he sent
it to everyone
it's a very well is it his notes 100
it's a very
well thought out icebreaker yeah that
he's putting his notes because he knows
he has to jump through these dumb hoops
it's annoying i actually like the fact
that speaking of like dating apps and
stuff obviously you said on bumble i've
never been on it like
they have to let the woman holler you
first you said you were on it before
right
what was your experience on it in terms
of
in comparison to tinder because
obviously with tinder women would wait
for a year before they holly you
what pains me to say was back then what
my experience was it was exactly the
same
okay i feel like women swipe with more
chest on bumble because they know you
can't pester them
[Music]
so
i from all the swipes i've
from all the swipes i got hardly any of
them message me and there's nothing you
can do until they message you no wow
i'll sit there and wait
and it could be you can say you got a
match
as well sam i got i remember i got a
couple matches from
banging things never message me
because they don't have to because a lot
of girls just go on dating apps because
they're bored
and for um self um just like an ego
stroke that's the thing yeah because
they're bored bro because they've
already got man in the dms anyway with
blue ticks galore if they're banging
enough
they don't need this they don't need
tinder
yeah it's tough man
it's tough but anyway moving on um i've
got undermine the [ __ ] and then we
will wrap it up by the way i'm watching
afterlife i'm like season three
dope show
dope show the comedy and it's amazing
the fat first scene in the the school
yeah
the pedo thing hilarious hilarious my
stuff the whole thing the whole thing is
the [ __ ] psychiatrist is
[ __ ] funny
which one's that the the psychiatrist
who plays him i don't know his name bro
it's just the bearded brother with the
glasses yeah yeah he mentions like this
all the time yeah yeah i remember i
remember i remember living that life i
remember i remember why do you come up
with me and the boys you know writing
the nonce yeah yeah yeah i remember
wasting funny
funny bro i remember i remember i
remember
i remember
anyway um
okay cool this is a different one i like
this one right dang i love different
ones so am i the [ __ ] for keeping a
lost pet until the owner paid the
rewarding fee that was advertised
okay
fair enough fam i'm intrigued already
same i'm intrigued already that and the
good thing is that's all i've read i
haven't read the rest of it okay that's
all i've read okay i'm very intrigued
all right uh there was this cat that
kept coming up um sorry man there was
this cat that kept on coming to my
garden it would con it was con wow he
he you know what's funny he double
messaged
what do you mean you double message he
messaged the whole thing and then he
messaged the whole thing again oh god
and then he messaged a third time saying
i read through it there's mistakes
i'm experiencing that now yeah yeah oh
so you're reading the first one not the
second i mean the first one but i don't
know if the second one is a correction
or if you just put it twice okay okay
okay okay okay all right let me go to
the second one just in here nope being
character nothing i can say already
ain't crazy nothing sailors right okay
let's start again am i the also for
keeping a lost pair until the owner paid
the rewarding fee that was advertised
there was this cat that kept on coming
into my garden
it was constantly coming throughout the
day but it would just leave when it was
dark i'm trying to read slow so i don't
get [ __ ] up on these these issues
a couple of days later i saw a poster
saying about a lost cat which looked
identical to the cat that i've been
roaming around in my garden
a few days later i saw the cat again in
my garden and i was able to grab it
easily as it was very friendly
i called the owner and said that i found
the cat from the advertised poster that
had the reward they seemed very happy
and said that they were able to come and
collect it the same day when he came to
collect the cat i mentioned about the
500 pound promise 500 pounds a healthy
reward
500 pound promise for the reward for
finding the cap
the owner said that there wasn't any
reward money as it was just to get
people to find his cat
okay say less okay i have an issue now
yeah yeah
we've got beef we've got beef and i've
got a cat unnecessary yeah yeah yeah of
course i'll shot your cat
i'll sell your cat
continue
i said that i wasn't going to pass over
the cat until i get the reward money
that you promised on the poster he got
really anky angry
angry
um and threatened to call the police if
i didn't hand over the cat i'll better
call him call the police
let's settle this this was your advert
we've got a contractual agreement if i
find the cat run me pee
i said that he was welcome to call the
police as i was okay with everything
going on paper if he decided to claim
against me gang i also said why promise
something if you aren't able to pay it
he left and said he would come back
later the night came he returned with
the money and i happily handed over the
cat
and that was that at the end of this i
decided to tell my girlfriend but she
wasn't happy about what i did by taking
the advan advantage of the situation as
it didn't cost me anything to find the
cat and
it wasn't right by demanding the money i
also mentioned
it to one of my friends and he just
laughed about the situation and said
that the reward was there to be taken
and i was acclaimed
okay in claiming it am i the [ __ ] no
i'm with the bedroom on this i'm in the
bridge no you're not the awesome you
can't be advertising certain things it's
not like he went searching for the cat
blah blah blah found it like he took his
time whatever no the cat was stumbling
in his garden day after day after day
night night after night after night
big man i found your cat i've stumbled
across your poster it says five bills
for this cat build you big man i got
your cat bring nippy exchange we can
part way it's transactional it's
literally transactional
because
if there was no poster
that's the thing as well is that from my
perspective that the 500 pound was
probably what alerted his attention to
the poster of course
it was just a picture of a cat he
wouldn't care he would have walked past
it and
maybe wouldn't have even put two and two
together and this cat running in his
garden is the same [ __ ] cat that's on
the poster i would never but if i'm
supposed to say have you seen this cat
five bills i see five bills and i'm
running back to double check the cat's
eyes to make sure they match oh hundreds
i mean 100
so 100 yeah if you're gonna advertise it
doesn't even matter because i don't owe
you [ __ ] i don't know your opinion you
lost your cat
it's not my fault
so yeah if you're advertising five bills
because at the same time i'm sure i
can't speak for this guy i don't know
what kind of personality he has but your
everyday citizen if they did notice the
poster without the reward and saw the
cat i'm sure that they're gonna be the
kind of person says i'm sure that's the
cat from the poster i'll send it back i
know i would the same way if there was
no reward and i found the cat i would
still give the cat back but if there is
a reward
don't you
dare tell me
it was just it was just a ruse
just to employ to make people find my
cat yeah excuse me no you lost your cat
can't trick people like that yeah 100
like that's a scam that's actually a
scam yeah you're scamming people to get
people to do your work for you so
scabbing people you're basically saying
i need more eyes doing my job for me
i've lost my cat and it's my job to find
the cat i need help finding the cat
so let me trick people into doing what i
want them to do and once they've done it
then i'll get what i want that's [ __ ]
free labor that's what he's done imagine
imagine you you that sent the thing or
whatever the the person that lost the
cat imagine you going to work and your
boss tells you oh you got to stay four
hours later this week we will pay you
though yeah double time double time we
will pay you
are you like [ __ ] it all right you come
home you see your paycheck on friday
they paid you [ __ ]
and uh we just gassed you yeah i just
need the work i just needed the work
done and i didn't know how else to get
it done without saying i'm gonna pay you
man more take it or leave it oh you're
going court exactly you know big man you
have to run the five bills 100 left yeah
you can't you can't do this to people
you can't do that you physically can't
do that to people so yeah 100
as soon even if i wasn't bothered about
the 500 pounds it's the principle it's
the principle that you just told me
oh i don't have five bills i just needed
people to find the cat 100 you're giving
me you're giving me you'll give me the
five pills or at least shot in your cat
oh hundred percent i'm shocking your cat
that's it 100 you're not the [ __ ] you
are not you want to ask not the artist
nowhere near the arsenal he's the
[ __ ] awesome yeah he's an [ __ ] for
[ __ ] lying standard
standards but anyway that was a very
good amount of the answer we haven't had
okay they're usually about cheating
boyfriends and all this stuff like yeah
we haven't had an original one of that
in a minute so thank you for that bro um
but guys as always
happy to have you here enjoy the rest of
the week
get on over to patreon.com forward shits
and gigs and join us on thursday um and
as always if you're a
[ __ ] then we'll see you next monday
yeah yeah all right guys love love
[Music]